this mayor of boston is sort of the
anti-desantis he's probably the best
executive leader in america right now
this woman is one of the worst
and she just came out
and this was on her st patrick's day
breakfast and she was complaining about
the snow and she said you know don't
worry she's used to dealing with
problems
that are that are disruptive and white
in just over 100 days we have connected
unhoused residents at mass and cast to
housing treatment and services
we've launched three free bus lines
we've taken some big bold actions but i
won't lie
this past winter was pretty intense
trial by snow
trial by fire fighters union
i'm getting used to dealing with
problems that are expensive disruptive
and white
i'm talking about snowflakes snowflakes
i mean snow storm snowflakes
not exactly don rickles okay not she's
not quite a rodney dangerfield is she
she's got to work on that comedic
timing and i i think she should work on
her material
her material the actual content of her
here's this was the joke i hate white
people that's the joke white people are
terrible i hate them
i i'm an asian woman i hate white people
hahaha white people are bad haha
we are told in this very
stupid and deluded culture we are told
that white people are privileged and
everyone else is oppressed
in reality the opposite is true the only
group that it is legal to discriminate
against is white people in some cases
you can also discriminate against asians
who get lumped in with white people for
some reason ironic given this woman's
joke
but it's really primarily white people
that are permitted to be discriminated
against on the social scene the only
race that you can criticize that you're
actually encouraged to criticize and
mock and deride on the basis of race is
white people so
the the narrative that we are told is
the opposite
of what is actually going on in reality
there's such an irony here i mentioned
just a few moments ago
that the difference between the races is
really relatively minor compared to the
difference between the
sexes you know
christianity is quite clear about this
right there is uh
neither jew nor greek nor slave nor free
but all are one in christ jesus the
racial difference is really
not all that significant sexual
difference still is quite significant
right in in the beginning there there
was man
male and female uh god created them
and yet what we're told today
is exactly the opposite it's a total
inversion
of christianity of our religious
tradition we are told that the
difference between men and women
basically doesn't exist and the
difference between the races is
insurmountable you see this
everywhere that this
liberal ideology leftist radical call it
whatever you want
it seems always not just to distort but
to totally invert
our traditional understanding of our
culture and it's true here on race and
sex
traditionally
race less significant sex much more
significant here you totally flip it i'm
so glad that you liked that clip i did
as well if you want to get all of the
episodes you got to subscribe ring that
bell head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitcher google play great place
to subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review and also head
on over to dailywire.com check out our
new three-part docu-series fouchy
unmasked you will get the true
never-before-seen story of dr fauci's
rise to power and maybe how to stop it
from rising to power again we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]